[Music]
when we think about wildfires we often
see images of singed animals
and burning buildings fires add harmful
smoke into the air
and emit greenhouse gases they can
destroy homes
and lives but they aren't all bad
fires keep countless ecosystems healthy
they clear out dead brush that blocks
new plant growth
they add nutrients back into the soil
many plants flourish after a fire
lodgepole pines make some pine cones
that are covered in a layer of wax
it protects the seeds until a fire comes
through once the pine cones are exposed
to hot temperatures
the wax melts and the seeds are free
[Music]
ecosystems are used to a certain fire
regime which is a pattern of wildfire
some places need more some places need
less
for example tropical rainforests with
thin bark trees
aren't adapted to a lot of fire it can
quickly burn through the bark
and kill the trees on the other hand
many grasslands need regular fires that
keep larger bushes and trees from taking
hold
otherwise they may turn into woodlands
squeezing out the animals that used to
live there
because of human activity places around
the world are going through rapid
changes to their fire regimes
as people convert grassland to farmland
and move closer to wildfire prone areas
they've stopped natural fires from
burning this has happened in places
including brazil
tanzania and the eurasian steppe
slash and burn agriculture is causing
more fires in the amazon and indonesian
tropical forests
meanwhile climate change is lengthening
fire seasons in places used to fire
these devastating blazes are hard to
recover from
so how can we approach fire in a way
that balances human health
and recognizes it as a natural process
that promotes biodiversity
it requires a multifaceted approach for
one
we can let natural wildfires burn in
some areas
decades of fire suppression have led to
a build-up of dry logs and leaves
this can cause out-of-control blazes
places like yellowstone national park in
the united states are allowing small
natural fires
these make a patchwork of burned and
unburned areas
that increases the kinds of plants and
animals that can thrive there
when fires do rage we can protect areas
that may not be able to survive
during the 2019-2020 australian fires
firefighters worked to save a growth of
prehistoric trees called willow my pines
fewer than 200 of these trees exist in
the wild
firefighters set up irrigation to keep
the grove wet
and surrounded it with fire retardant
they managed to save the trees
we can also try to improve the health of
each ecosystem
one way is to reintroduce and protect
animals that are important to their
habitats
in south africa researchers found that
fires were 50 times smaller
when rhinos grazed the land the rhinos
kept plants from growing out of control
their paths created fire breaks or gaps
in vegetation
large grazers like the white rhino can
rebalance ecosystems and reset their
fire regimes
finally we can lean on ages old fire
approaches
in china people have planted green fire
breaks to manage wildfires for over a
thousand years
these sections don't burn as easily as
their surroundings
recently the chinese government planted
more than 364 thousand kilometers of
green fire breaks
indigenous australians have lit fires in
the bush for fifty thousand years
to hunt clear paths and invigorate the
land
areas without these fires have larger
and more dangerous blazes that are
triggered by lightning
using indigenous strategies for the land
can help manage fires in a sustainable
way
challenges are ahead but an integrated
approach to fire
may help us and the planet
[Music]
you